[Music]
well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what is
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the sun
pippa crera and harry cole they are both
in new york covering the prime
minister's trip to the un climate summit
and they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight nice and early for
you too i'll speak to you in just a
moment front pages then let's start
shall we with the guardian carries
warnings of a possible winter of
discontent amid worries about the
reliability of energy and food supplies
according to the telegraph energy
companies are lobbying the government to
scrap the price cap in order for them to
stay in business but the time says
dozens of energy firms will be left to
collapse with the government saying it
won't bail them out
financial times leading with the
business secretary quasi quatang
insisting there is no question of the
lights going out this winter as the gas
crisis intensifies while the express
says the government has promised to
protect people from crippling energy
bills
daily star claims that supply issues
mean we could run out of various kinds
of meat within days
in other news the metro reporting on
what it calls a sleepover massacre in
which two children their mother and
their school friend were killed in
derbyshire
it's the same stories you can see
leading the sun
so let's get the uh thoughts then of
pippakura and harry cole we will delve
deeply into the uh what the prime
minister is expecting from his meeting
with joe biden tomorrow a bit later but
first of all the energy crisis here in
the uk
at the guardian harry prepare for a
winter of discontent the business
secretary earlier in the commons saying
you know don't worry it's not going to
be like the 1970s the lights will stay
on there won't be a three-day week
that's not entirely encouraging is it as
a place to start
yes when uh when
when a minister has to stand up in
parliament and say don't worry you know
it's not we're not going back to the 70s
your first instant thinking is oh my
gosh it's that bad if they're already
soothing fears the prime minister since
he's been here it feels like he's
slightly out of the action um
over in new york and he's coming up with
some ever increasingly uh
strange metaphors to try to try soothe
fears about what's happening he says
it's like the the global economy is
waking up like gulliver and he's being
the guy ropes pinging everywhere as a as
a sort of beast of the global trade
starts to pick up again post covid then
he's saying it's like a great thor after
a frost you know has some issues and he
says like everyone's turned the kettle
on after watching a tv program there's
just gonna be a bit of a bit of a
bottleneck in the system that's all very
well but you know that bottleneck
they're unable to say well how long
that's going to last it could be up to a
few months that they're saying and at
the same time um warnings coming up down
the street and the business department
they're not going to bail out failing
companies just because their business
models haven't stress tested this stuff
so a big fight with business coming and
at the end of the day you know people's
bills are going up and they're going to
see this uh these issues these rises and
gas prices reflected very quickly in
their monthly payments and that's when i
think things are going to get very
tricky for the government yes despite
the price cap the prices will still go
up daily telegraph from the point of
view of the energy companies at least
four small energy companies have already
folded pippa in recent weeks uh quasi
quoting in the commons we're still
saying we must not return to the sort of
you know anti-competitive market where
there are a few big players but that's
what's going to end up happening isn't
it if they don't fix this because
if you have a cap on the price consumers
will pay um but these companies are
paying more
buying in stock effectively um
there's a pinch point isn't there
yeah the suggestion is that well at the
moment there's 55 energy companies that
operate in the uk domestic market and
the suggestion is that they could end up
as a result of this just going down to
10 which obviously you know dramatically
uh hits the industry and quasi-quarting
has had meetings with energy suppliers
over the last couple of days and the
telegraph reports that repeatedly in
those meetings the energy providers have
urged him to lift the price cap so that
they can put up prices on consumers in
order to afford the um you know the
increases in in wholesale prices which
have gone up 80
since um july now the government has
been quite clear in quasi-courting
obviously said in the comments today
um number 10 privately and and other
departments making it quite clear that
their priority is going to be consumers
um of course any
um they've said that the the cap saves
15 million households about 100 pounds
on their energy bills every year and as
you rightly say anna the prices are due
to go up anyway because they're reviewed
every six months on the first of october
it's going to add another i think it's
130 pounds or thereabouts to um to the
average dual fuel
energy energy bill so the government's
really going to resist um ongoing
pressure they made it quite clear the
consumers come first and the businesses
come second um but uh you know as harry
mentioned it's not just obviously energy
prices that are going up there's all
sorts of costs coming up uh this winter
leading to this the so-called winter of
discontent there's universal credit cuts
which is going to affect six million
families um they're going to lose 20
pounds a week or thousand pounds a year
um food prices are potentially going to
go up because of uh shortages and
problems with supply chains and then of
course there's a natural national
insurance hike next year for many
working people as well so you know the
government will be very
will be very wary about an increased
energy price on
on top of that when already there's a
real cost of living crisis that many
people are facing that could really
damage uh the tory's standing with
photos yes and uh the daily telegraph uh
quoting the business secretary saying
the government will not be bailing out
failed companies stressing there would
be no rewards for failure or
mismanagement for suppliers left
vulnerable by failing to hedge
sufficiently so these are unhedged or
effectively uninsured against rising
wholesale prices um not buying in
advance like some of the big boys but uh
buying on the spot markets which makes
it extremely expensive for them the
times going with the same effect really
dozens of energy firms will be left to
collapse um and i suppose the idea that
the big boys um as he called them would
then have to pick up all these customers
well at the same time losing money
because of the prices or getting support
from the government to
to meet the difference i guess harry
yeah i think the government think
they're in a stronger position than it
appears uh
on this obviously they are under
pressure to bail out companies and to
provide incentives i think there will be
some some help and assistance but i
don't think you'll be any anywhere near
the scale that some people would hope it
would be because the government
basically believed that actually now
it's not like the 1970s we do actually
have a pretty diverse
um
uh supply chain in terms of any uh
diverse sources of energy from wind to
gas to even if we've been firing up some
of the coal power stations which boris
johnson's like here telling everyone
else they've got to get rid of over the
last uh over the last few weeks um they
think there are in a strong position
they do think that they'll be able to
ride this out but it might take a couple
of weeks for the sort of kinks in the
system to uh to to filter out but there
are there are other levers and the
bailout uh uh that they can pull
including a deal done with norway to try
and produce more gas in the coming weeks
which they're hoping will um take some
of that pressure off the of the prices
yes and there's multiple issues to this
story as the daily star so helpfully
points out
will meet again don't know where don't
know when is their front page
and the idea is that gas prices is one
part of this story
a byproduct is carbon dioxide which is
used in all forms of food production
especially for meat for chicken and pigs
and then there's the inflationary
pressure of of all of this isn't there
pippa
yes and it will be something that the
government will be asked about
repeatedly i imagine in the coming
months if there are ongoing uh supply
chain issues with uh when it comes to
foods the obviously the gas the gas
price hike is a factor because of the
impact as you say has had on co2 which
is used to produce um and to store
chilled meat but there's also the the
lorry driver shortage the whole air
shortage shortages the government's
trying to address part of that is about
frankly lots of people don't really
fancy the job anymore but also obviously
brexit has an impact there because many
drivers were european and either can't
or don't want to travel to the united
kingdom now
um but clearly that then has a knock-on
effect on how quickly quickly it's um
you can get food from depots to or
producers to stores and appointing more
appointing more uh lorry drivers and
paying them a higher wage encouraging
them into the industry will take time um
so you know there's potentially going to
be a problem in the run-up to christmas
which of course is not the time that
anybody wants to have to do without
their pigs in blankets absolutely yes uh
one of the largest um producers
suggesting they'd have to cut chicken um
chickens on the shelves by 10 which
would have an instant impact um
and the question i suppose stretches to
your paper the sun in fact your article
could we import that famous chlorinated
chicken from america if when we had a
trade deal harry a bit of a segue i
suppose um but what what is what have we
heard from the prime minister on the
prospect of a trade deal ahead of this
meeting with joe biden in the oval
office tomorrow
well uh pippa and i came over on the raf
voyage with the prime minister on sunday
night monday morning and uh gave a bit
of a grilling on
a wide range of subjects you'd say
including you know what on earth is
going on with this with this brexit
trade deal with uh with the united
states this trust when she was trade
secretary was set a target of perhaps
doing it by 2022. it's all gone very
quiet since biden took over and for the
first time the prime minister actually
admits this to us quite candidly
actually he said look joe biden's got
bigger fish to fry at the moon sorry not
a lot of fish to fry at the moment which
sounds an awful lot
like uh a chilling warning given by
barack obama in 2016 when he said that
brexit would in fact be back at the
queue for a trade deal now it's not that
america are doing trade deals left right
and centered with other countries i
think they're trying to negotiate with
kenya at the same time um it's the fact
is that you know covenant obviously has
blown things out the water the situation
in afghanistan and boris johnson seems
to be blaming uh joe biden's vast
domestic infrastructure spending and
building back better and things like
that but it feels very much like uh
progress is stalled and i'm not sure
that tomorrow's visit to the white house
is going to do very much to get it going
so don't hold your breath on uh on a
vast u.s trader anytime soon stepping in
to ease some of these issues because it
feels to me like it's many years off yet
yeah we're gonna have plenty more time
to talk about this there's so much to
say isn't there as we look at the
picture in the sun there of uh the prime
minister shaking the hand of the
brazilian president as he urged him to
protect the the rainforest as part of
the commitments to try and reduce co2
and cop26 but uh pippa you'll get
yourself that a little bit later thank
you very much need both of you lots more
still to come including more from the
states britain's soon able to travel to
america without restrictions debating
that just a moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now people and harry
cole both in new york uh with the prime
minister effectively and we were talking
about his visit there and a billy bonus
pippa i suppose for him
is this decision by america to um lift
the travel ban on brits heading to the
states
yes 18 months ago donald trump at the
start of the pandemic imposed a complete
blanket ban on anybody coming from
abroad uh to the united states and as a
british citizen it's been impossible if
you've been in the uk for the previous
14 days to travel to the us and
even even if you um had
uh there were some exemptions if you
worked here if you're a u.s citizen as
well or a family of europe citizen and
other sort of a few visa there's a few
other sort of ways through visas that
you could do it but it's basically
impossible to come to the united states
and the announcement today um from the
white house basically confirms that if
you're double-jabbed and you're from
abroad then you will be allowed to come
to uh come to the us so harry and i
traveled here obviously we had a work
exemption but you know from the
beginning of november anybody with a
double jab um will be able to travel
over which opens up all the you know the
business that has been
done remotely um for the last 18 months
but also holidays for people if they
fancy popping up to new york or to
disneyland or florida um
it seems to be that um the united states
is going to accept any of the vaccines
which are um
which have been uh
regarded as approved by the british
regulators for example zenica which
obviously isn't really used in the
united states that will still count so
if you've had nasa jab you can come here
and the suggestion is as well that
children who obviously in the uk haven't
been double jabbed yet or even jabbed in
some cases will be able to travel with
their vaccinated parents so that those
sorts of details will have to be
confirmed but it's uh you know prime
minister who stays very lucky he was um
talking to us on the plane on the way
over and he made it quite clear that we
shouldn't hold our breaths for this
announcement coming anytime soon clearly
we was blindsided by the announcement um
number 10 claimed that he was he was
tipped off in advance but it sounds like
it was only a few a matter of minutes or
maybe even hours in advance and and
certainly not before they traveled over
but the bottom line is there'll be very
many people some of the four four
million people who travel to the states
every year um pre-pandemic will be many
people especially those who are going to
be united with family that they haven't
seen for a very long time will be very
happy tonight absolutely they will and
as we look at the uh the metro harry
which is um a furious driver
uh cross at these m25 protesters
suggesting that i know what you're
fighting for but you're wrecking lives
and making people hate you the whole
question about direct action um worth
bearing in mind that for the prime
minister i suppose the focus has to be
the cop 26 uh summit doesn't it and
trying to get america to contribute to
this 100 billion dollars a year fund to
help
emerging countries battle climate change
yeah i think the point i think a lot of
people feel is that yeah you can agree
with some of the calls you can agree
with the with the noble aims but the
tactics are just gonna annoy people and
just gonna drive people away from your
calls and it's completely
counterproductive you've got a lot of
middle class lefties sitting in the
middle of a motorway and people are
trying to go to work in the middle of a
supply chain you know crisis that's
already existing you just think it's
going to be you know
for what minuscule step forward you're
going to achieve from this process it's
going to be
step back and step back and step back in
bringing the public with you on this and
frankly
uh you know i think they deserve a
little bit more than a ticking off from
a van drive indeed so he looked very
cross in the picture certainly um both
of you lovely to have you on from the
states thank you both very much indeed
pipakura and harry kolder reporting from
america ahead of that meeting with the
prime minister